roughly 30 percent of americans now have
at least
one shot of the kobit 19 vaccine leading
to loosening of travel restrictions
thank you for joining us at six
i'm brian loftis and i'm christian
casadas after prior cautionary warnings
the cdc
says you are now safe to travel around
the united states
if you're vaccinated joe muller is live
on the strip with more
joe well previously people were
encouraged to avoid unnecessary travel
but now the cdc says if you have your
vaccine you are safe to travel around
the country
today we caught up with visitors here in
las vegas some say they feel better
that more people are getting their
vaccines others say they don't really
care
i don't care yeah the vaccination i
don't
it is what it is vaccine or not some say
they will still travel
i don't really care whether people are
vaccinated or not
you know it kind of varies between
opinion others feel safer of course it's
encouraging to see the more people are
and of course the first responders the
teachers the people that need it the
most
and i understand hopefully the
hospitality workers soon in vegas
but yeah it's certainly encouraging
friday the center for disease control
and prevention released new guidelines
for vaccinated americans
if you have your shots the agency says
you are safe to travel around the
country
you are advised to wear mass and
socially distance you do not need to get
a cobin 19 test before leaving though
some destinations may require it i think
we're moving towards the right direction
ivy lagman from blissful travel expects
travel to pick up as more shots are
administered and destinations still
offer deals
occupancy levels are low and they're
offering
lower rates to attract people to come
because
because of that she is still waiting for
international travel guidelines the
vaccine is influencing some people's
plans
i felt fine i just wore my mask the
whole time samantha brodine is from
south dakota
her family lives here and waited to have
her visit until they had their vaccine
we didn't want to expose her to bring
something back or
vice versa
and the cdc says if you do not have your
vaccine you are urged to avoid
unnecessary travel continuing here on
now reporting live in las vegas strip
joe muller 8 news now